8:24 was the studio that brought us my
favorite horror film of 2017 it comes at
night and judging from what people have
been saying about this movie at Sundance
it sounds like their new film hereditary
could be another success yesterday we
got a trailer for it and it does look
promising
look closer however and you'll see some
downright creepy details and things that
just don't add up seemingly on purpose
if you want to hear the one consistency
I did find then make sure to stick
around to the end of this video this is
things you missed let's just start at
the beginning of the trailer
it opens on this miniature model of the
house it appears to be the house that
they live in which shows up about midway
through the trailer this piece sitting
on the chair should end up going right
here on the front of the house the
garage doors are the same for both and
the front entrance in overall shape of
the house seemed consistent but then you
notice this window is missing from the
model and the colors are changed
entirely
the model has beige wood with green
frames while the house is brown with
dark brown frames in another shot we can
also confirm that the real house is
missing this section too now it could
just be that she's using the miniatures
to plan a remodel or something or she's
an architect as evidenced by these
blueprints that reuses the same design
elements in many of her works such as
the garage door and the front door but
what makes me think otherwise is that
there are other inconsistencies in the
trailer begging to be noticed the
treehouse is missing from the model
altogether and because the treehouse
looks like a small separate house you
have to wonder if she just sees it as
another one of her creations just a
crazy guess here because we don't know a
whole lot about this movie yet but maybe
the mother starts to break down later in
the movie and lose his sight of the
difference between her real family and
the figurines one more thing from this
opening shot before we move on there are
two creepy photos pinned up in the
corner of the room I'm not sure what the
first one is but please let me know your
thoughts in the comments but the second
one looks like a pair of feet standing
in an overexposed doorway you're not
convinced let me crank up the contrast
for you now let's look at the shot later
in the trailer where the mom finds the
figurine of her deceased mother standing
in the doorway
connection not definite but absolutely a
possibility
here's another inconsistency outside of
the immediate family which is these guys
none of the people at the burial are the
same people who attend the service see
how they're a bunch of bearded guys at
the service none at the burial see these
bald guys at the burial not at the
service the burial has four kids the
only kid at the services of the daughter
as far as I can tell the immediate
family are the only ones to attend both
events the mother even comments it's
heartening to see so many strange new
faces here today I know my mom would be
very touched what does that even mean
why would you want strangers at your
mother's funeral
like I said something doesn't add up but
it gets weirder the daughters drawing a
picture of her mother hysterical and
crying at the podium but we see at the
podium the mom is fine it's at the
burial that she's hysterical also on the
other page what is this this is
terrifying
if these drawings turn out to be a
telling of things to come then this is
gonna be one freaky scene the necklace
the mother wears can also be seen on the
dead grandma as well so it could be a
symbol for the hereditary passing down
of trades just as biological genes are
passed down the tradition of the
necklace could also be passed down what
I can't figure out is what this shape is
supposed to be let me know your
interpretation in the comments but as
far as I can tell there are three
consecutive figures possibly signifying
daughter and mother and grandmother next
one is more disturbing when you think
more about it why did this woman make a
tiny model of her own mother on her
deathbed I shudder to think about what
kind of person does this and if that
wasn't strange enough
it looks like the daughter also draws
the dead grandma this family needs a new
hobby if I'm not mistaken it looks like
the grandmas eyes are opening on the
other page which is out of focus which
again will be very unsettling if true
maybe you all picked up on this right
away but the next thing is another one
that just got creepy after I thought
about it for a second you know you
weren't a favorite
even here a little baby she would let me
feed you because she needed to feed you
because she needed to feed you because
she made a defeat you
hopefully they were talking about baby
formula but let's face it it's way too
late for that here's some weird things I
noticed about the daughter she's always
wearing orange
she always has these strings tied around
her finger she's got this weird
connection with Birds a bird crashes
into a classroom window she cuts a
bird's head off with scissors totally
normal
she has pictures of birds in her room
there's also a bird ornament sitting in
a nest in her room you could even say
her whole room kind of resembles a
birdhouse if you think of a birdhouse as
a miniature house that hangs on a tree
so is this speaking of her room first of
all super cool I mean what kid would not
want to live in that but on the inside
well this guy's just lovely and what's
the point of having indoor wind chimes
anyway I think that's enough of the girl
for now she's kind of freaky let's move
on to the son I don't know if it's just
me but he looks way older than his
classmates I mean look at this kid look
at her now look at the son looks like he
got held back a couple times but given
what happens next
I can kind of see why also there's a
poster on the wall behind him that just
says big it could be because everything
in this movie seems to have a miniature
version and if the lines do start to
blur at some point as I predicted there
may be clues about which world were in I
think we've established that the kid is
kind of disturbed so the sign of the
school that has the words help and
counselor probably foreshadow a scene
that takes place at side counselor's
office involving the kid you may have
noticed in this quick shot that the head
from the doll is missing but what you
most likely overlooked is that this is
actually supposed to be the son Peter
the dresser right here is the same as
this dresser I've seen in his room and
the position of the bed in relation to
the desk also matches the shade of his
blue pajamas seem to be the same as what
the doll is wearing and the color of the
wall and the location of the stripe all
match up but of course there had to be
inconsistencies like the missing blinds
or the added carpets I think we can
assume that his head smashing tendencies
are probably related to why the doll has
no head but it also looks like something
is trying to pull his head off just
before
and as promised there's one major
consistency that could be a big clue as
to what's making this family so crazy
at the end of the trailer this flare
transitions the mothers face into the
daughter a similar flare is seen
traveling down the hall at the Sun
school I'd love to hear your thoughts
about this so let me know what you think
in the comments if you're looking
forward to hereditary and then leave
this video a like and if you're too
scared then check out my horror comedy
web series The Walking Dead instead but
regardless of your choice I'm gonna be
covering all the best horror movies of
2018 so make sure you subscribe to seize
these worlds for new Horrors every week
bring that death benefit and I'll see
you in the next one
assuming we both survive what